gino muore ragazzi si rivede e questo
penso sia il detto più azzeccato in
assoluto per questo gioco se lo ragazzi
su paint the town red che non so se ve
lo ricordate ma era una bomba pazzesca
che questo gioco dove i picchi con la
gente e non saprei perché non so come
diavolo giocare all'euro perché hanno
fatto uscire cose nuove a quanto pare
però non so bene ho scaricato ragazzi
escape the roman prison che non aveva
ancora fatto visita alla kick pick up
weapon newspower ma ormai perché mele
non mi ricordavo assolutamente più nulla
madonna io sono in una prigione romana
in tutto sto casino va bene dal re
lancia il caso di friendly quindi con un
amico che lo devo salvare però non vi
siete accorti che era completamente
aperta la porta c'è prove grazie prendo
questo trovo è pronta ok off shore
mi scusi non volevo salve ho picchiato
dammi una mano con lario si è confuso
non so se le mio amico nemico perché lo
più che ha fatto lui e picchia porco
demonio e non lo so questi sono i poteri
dammi la mano non so le cose lo so le
cose non capì ecco aspettami questo
barca è morto
aiuto mi piace se le fai a che palle e
basta poi recupero la vita mi sono fatto
buongiorno se qua se guardate tutti una
trappola questa mi scusi
non so ma io non volevo cie che è che
questo gioco non è in realtà molto fermi
di friendly non so se avete notato con
quello e non è intanto replay facciamo
solo per capire la team i comandi e non
è che mi interessasse molto la vittoria
ma fa niente la 12 ecco gli stavolta ha
fatto molto più in fretta dammi la mano
ti ho salvato il culo grazie domani vado
di qui vai sempre molto confuso prendi
bravo lo zio ha capito vai frate amaci
gente 4 gente nuda che si tocca vai
avanti vai avanti frate va avanti occhio
che arriva uno anzi due
picchia picchia porca vacca che botte ai
a chiave la madonna spaccato tutto qua
dami questo parco lemonia parco lemonia
tagliate male porco demonio diventato
molto più difficile suo gioco perché non
morivi così facilmente ultima volta però
ci sono anche i poteri bene lei si usa
power smart o di roma lo ricordavo c'è
poi sparare alla gente col gol a mano
che la madonna ragazzi poi non dite che
non vi porto giochi della madonna
ho finito basta non è morto porca ma
cocchio aiuto luce divina
minchia meno male
tutto a posto salve non l'avevo vista
lei sta in georgia buttare che è questo
qua eh no vabbè rischio tanta gente è
spuntata gente che non vedevo mi scusi
lei stia per terra grazie molto gestire
lei pure a ma non lasciare la lanciati
serve anche per l'altro
ma porca vacca porca la mia arma o bravo
vince che botta a pugni
l'hack è male barca vaccara che
dificilissimo sto gioco veramente non so
devo usare per forza questo ok
meno male che c'è un range d'attacco
pazzesco ragazzi non ho capito come
faccio a recuperarla vita perché sono
morto io sono morto buongiorno
meno male ma cosa state dando fuoco ma
siete pazzi cioè queste sono le prigioni
romane più brutto che abbia mai visto
non lascia i due in fondo è comunque di
tizi che lasciano libertà salve aspetti
che proposto potere che non ho ben
capito cos'è amica lo shockwave che
adesso ha ricordato sono arrivati i
soccorsi
c'è gente che mi aiuta meno male perché
è un casino
allora mori mori mori di nuovo fuori
sempre è che palle o che ha posto una
squadra italiana aperto c'è una spada di
fuoco quello che è sciocco i brevi
minchiate botta no vabbè ragazzi non
puoi resistere delle botte così è
schiatta che palle madonna ragazzino
nemici rimasti poi ho vinto madonna ma
incredibile ma non muore mai è
impossibile a uccidere no ragazzi non ci
credo io ho lasciato di tutto ma basta
dei morire e 800 mila proiettili non è
morto un ragazzo e sono morto io adesso
cioè non facevano posso farvi niente
sono morto sam raimi in frenata
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi porco
demonio è difficilissimo cavolo
veramente un casino ma torna uno spadone
incredibile ci siamo zio vieni al
momento smythe
mi chiedono aiutare tutti è questo ma
dopo reali che il casinò è l'unico modo
raga è l'unico modo perché sono amore
nessuno va aiutato il tipo che prima non
moriva mai vediamo cosa riesce fuori
teoricamente dovrei riuscirci madonna
ria il casinò è schiatta ancora lì
quello com'è possibile ci guarda e non
muore o donna e cosa ti devo lanciare ce
li ho fatti fuori tutti è rimasto solo
lui
pazzesca sarò no ma come mai è stato
madonna lascia in faccia fa malissimo re
maya a posto allora porco del demonio
smythe sma italo tantissimo ma rotto le
palle e quello basta e sto facendo fuori
tutti
c'è qua veramente ragazzi se non muore
adesso io vera non so cosa fare di giuro
gli sto sparando 65 mila proiettili si
sono small e colati tutti c'è più
nessuno manco voi mi chiamo guarda la
madonna ma che cristo nato in faccia e
tutto questo perché arriva scelta che da
altri alti non lo so comunque qua si è
creato un casino
e questo quello forte o era lui quello
fortissimo che non muoio mai ma per
chiaramente ragazzi incredibile
ok ok 4 ore mining attenzione tra le
mailing stavolta ci siamo
chi picchia te scusa a 1 per terra quart
dura mening è morto era quello per forza
perché guarda qua che bordello questo
era troppo forte incenerito totalmente
chiede marche rimasto due e poi ci sente
per terra che è svenuta e basta essere
qualcuno che non ho visto qui no c'è un
muro invisi a level compito e che quelli
erano gli ultimi due erano loro gli
ultimi due la serie li puoi anche
uccidere però non è necessario alla fine
del completamento del livello ok ci
siamo ragazzi proviamo a farne un altro
per vedere che cosa esce fuori vediamo
se riesco a farlo subito perché l'altro
io mi su tre ore lo tutori vale venti
volte
questo dovrebbe essere più alla mia
portata adesso vediamo non lo so
permesso già che parto senza poteri ma
cos'è
ma la guerra è una trincea buongiorno le
21 le tante aspettaci con la musica
attesa patch è copyright
salve no no ma poi è un casino madonna
che bordello la gara scioperi madonna e
board
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi
ragazzi posso mica combatte da solo che
so iron man la parco lemonia
dov'è che questi poteri potrei anche
somigliarci è però mi scusi molto bene
il vero che un'arma ha solo un
proiettile prova bene in guerra
fa niente ai apporto demonio speriamo
solo una persona e ne date altre di armi
chi posta pala è quasi inutile avere
madonna si dicono le braccia con la
piccola pala ayala non picchiare ma è
brutto idiotas e danni a parte to
schifoso di un lay dona manco manco
distingue rigori
manco quello di bello che non hanno più
la pista non hanno i colpi l'artista e
picchiano con la pistola come se ha
bisogno di sé fare danni in qualche modo
già non lo so ma non vive dice io sono
io ma siete scemi
io sono il vostro compagno madonna
guarda sono tuo compagno non hai capito
niente turi come funziona quirico gli
altri e colpire non io
sei scemo forte lei e non ho ben capito
se devo far fuori tutti i miei compagni
non miei compagni un casino qua
aiuto mi sono cagato addosso era
arrivata gente non me n'ero accorto se
mi toccano sono morto che è perfetto da
mediatori e poi massa solo chi tenta di
uccidermi siete nemici voi due o
perfetto ho appena visto la scena più
bella del mondo e questo gli è svenuto
sopra bue
nel dubbio ancora gente lì ma porca
vacca
ma basta ma basta ammazzateli tra di voi
porca put up io non ho fatto veramente
niente non ho capito il perché l'aget
forse perché con lo show quelli o
colpiti non lo so non ho capito sta roba
ciò che mi servirebbe uno smile
piuttosto casinò sarebbe molto utile
meta ma siete ancora vivi o aiuto
bordello vorrei darvi una mano per
ammazzarli tutti però non è così
semplice ragazzi non è così semplice
sparo l'agente poi
ok perfetto di come sono morti il
piccone ok cav h
[Musica]